ah
listen to me
we need to unite these people out there
she's the face of this rebellion they'll
follow her
she won't be able to handle it
it's all gone there is no district 12.
plan was always to get you out
better for you to know nothing
you have been our mission from the
beginning
it's different for you
family needs you
you have to live for them listen to me
you're stronger than they are you are
i never wanted to be in the games
i just wanted to save my sister
remember who the real enemy is
this is the revolution
and you are the mockingjay
this is a pirate transmission
i want everyone who's watching
to lay down their weapons now you're
alive peta is the capital's weapon
i just don't want to be another piece in
their game you know
i'm i'm gonna die but they don't own me
i want to still be me i just can't
afford to think like that
you will rescue peta at the earliest
opportunity or you will find another
mockingjay
no one else can do this but her are you
fighting katniss
are you here to fight with us
i will
prepare to pay the ultimate
if we burn
you burn with us
you